- Sacha Milky-Merazil dit avoir
été interpelé une cinquantaine
de fois par la police. Comme
cette fois, en avril 2019.
- Pourriez-vous fermer
la porte s'il vous plaît,
Monsieur l'agent?
Il trouve que le jugement de la
Cour supérieure est un premier
pas dans la bonne direction.
SACHA-MILKY MERAZIL
- Je pense que les policiers
peuvent bien faire leur travail,
sans avoir à profiler, parce
que, justement, les policiers
sont là pour protéger et se
Et les citoyens des groupes
minoritaires, ont droit
à cette même protection.
- Dans son jugement
de 170 pages, le j
Michel Yergeau conclut que :
Même si la pratique était déjà
encadréeains corps
de police comme le SPVM,
pour plusieurs avocats,
la décision est historique
et pourrait faire jurisprudence
elle du pays.
Me NADA BOUMEFTAH, v.-p.,
Clinique juridique de St-Michel
- Ce jugement-là aujourd'hui
vient d'abord soulignerl'existe,
mais également le fait que
ce type de pratiques-là doit
cesser.
- Les policiers du Québec
devront renoncer aussi
aux barrages routiers pour
intercepter de potentiels
conducteurs en état d'ébriété.
PIERRE BROCHET, prés., Asso. des
directeurs de police du Québec
- On a beaucoup amélioré
le bilan au cours des 20-30
dernières années et on pense
qu'une des façons d'améliorer
le bilan c'est de permettre
aux policiers de vérifier l'état
de conduite.
- La mairesse de Montréal,
Valérie Plante, dit accueill
favorablement le jugement.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Il n'y a pas de place
dans notre société pour
le profilage social et racial.
Alors, c'est un jugement
qu'on considère qui est le bon.
- Alors que le premier ministre
François Legault,
émet quelques réserves.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Écoutez, c'est un jugement
qui est doit être
analysé. Par contre, quand on
parle d'interpellations
aléatoires, il faut comprendre
qu'il faut laisser les policiers
.
- Les policiers du Québec
auront un total de six mois
pour se conformer aux nouvelles
directives de la Cour
re. Mais un appel
de la décision pourrait bien
changer la donne.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Mon